[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans les 4V
François Baayou bonjour il vaut mieux
perdre une élection que perdre son âme
avait dit en son temps Michel Noir
pendant toute votre vie politique vous
avez mis les extrêmes à distance sans
jamais vous compromettre François Baayou
en mettant le sort du projet de loi
immigration entre les mains de Marine Le
Pen est-ce que ce gouvernement a perdu
son âme c'est le contraire ce que le
gouvernement a dit hier soir et a fait
hier soir a prouvé hier soir c'est que
si le texte était
passé par les voix de l'extrême droite
le gouvernement aurait retiré le texte
mais il est passé par les voies de
l'extrême droite non il a été
adopté en dehors des voies de l'extrême
droite et assez
largement avec une marge de sécurité qui
montre bien que ça n'est pas le
rassemblement national qui avait la clé
de ce vote sauf que si le rassemblement
national on va pas faire des des calculs
pendant 2 heures mais si le
rassemblement national voté contre le
texte aurait été rejeté donc le
gouvernement avait besoin des voix du RN
non je répète alors c'est pas la peine
de faire des polémiques parce qu'il y a
des choses assez graves en effet qui se
sont passées hier mais non le texte a
été adopté en dehors des voix du
rassemblement national et si il avait
dépendu de ses voix il aurait été retiré
par le gouvernement mais ce texte vous
en demandiez le retrait c'est ce que
disit Nathalie SAR tout à l'heure à 7h
et quart donc même sil a été AD
non bon euh non je n'ai jamais demandé
le retrait du texte j'ai demandé que le
texte respecte les deux principes
essentiels un qu'on estit de la rigueur
c'est-à-dire que les Français sachent
que on ne fait pas n'importe quoi en
France que le séjour irrégulier et bien
il est repéré sanctionné mais que on
peut s'intégrer par le travail il existe
une voie d'intégration une voie pour
être régulier dans notre pays et c'est
le travail et c'est exactement ce qui a
été imposé dans le texte d'hier mais par
exemple vous étiz hos hostile à la
caution pour les étudiants étrangers qui
viendront en France bien il n'y aura pas
de caution pour au moins pour les
étudiants boursiers ce qui lève cette
hypothèque il n'aurait pas été normal
que l'inscription dans une université
française dépende des moyens de
l'étudiant ou de la famille et donc de
ce point de vue là cette affaire a été
comme à peu près toutes les autres donc
ce texte il vous va la situation vous
convient là non la situation ne me
convient pas alors parce que on vit une
période de désordre et il faut se
méfier extrêmement du désordre quand
dans une démocratie ou une société de
liberté le désordre s'introduit dans les
esprits alors le risque est très grand
parce que évidemment on peut on peut se
trouver avec des peuples qui choisissent
la servitude on va dire je vis vous
montrer la de libération ce matin ce que
disait Emmanuel Macron le 24 avril 2022
après sa réélection vous m'avezlu pour
faire barrage à l'extrême droite ce vote
m'oblige et ce que disait Marine Le Pen
hier dans les couloirs de l'Assemblée
pour le RN la loi immigration signe une
victoire idéologique oui Marine Le Pen
elle a fait une manœuvre assez euh
réussi du point de vue de du jeu
parlementaire elle a voté contre ce
texte d'un bout à l'autre ils ont voté
contre ce texte au Sénat ils ont voté
contre les dispositions principales de
ce texte euh mais ils ont approuvé le
Tex qui sort de la et lorsqu'il est
sorti alors ils ont fait une manœuvre en
disant ce texte est le nôtre hier matin
le responsable du Front national
monsieur bardellaa disait s'il y a
régularisation jamais on ne votera ce
texte il y a régularisation il y a cette
voie ouverte à la régularisation par le
travail mais je suis pas du tout
satisfait de la situation et qu'est-ce
qui vous dérange le j'arrive pas à
comprendre ce qui vous dérange le plus
c'est le le contenu du texte c'est le
calendrier c'est la façon dont il a été
adopté qu'est-ce qui vous dérange le
plus tout euh dans ce dans cette période
a été euh
désordonné la la chose la plus euh
importante il y a eu au départ
une euh stratégie du gouvernement qui
consistait à s'entendre euh avec euh le
Sénat euh et notamment avec le groupe LR
au Sénat et autrement dit de faire
dépendre le texte de ce groupe-là puis
après il y a eu quelque chose que je
j'avoue je n'aurais jamais imaginé
l'Assemblée nationale a dit nous refus a
dit par la motion de rejet par une
alliance des extrêmes ouais nous
n'examinerons pas ce texte euh et je ne
sais pas si vous voyez la la gravité de
cette chose un pourquoi êtes-vous élu si
vous devant un texte que tous vous
déclarez essentiel ceux qui sont contre
et ceux qui sont pour disent c'est grave
c'est lourd et puis vous décidez de ne
pas l'examiner ce qui a complètement
déséquilibré le rapport de force oui
mais pardon au final François Baayou au
final hier soir quand on regarde les
vote il y a 59 voix qui manquent dans la
majorité sur 251 voix le président du
groupe modem de votre groupe Jean-Paul
Matth s'est abstenu parlons clairement
parce que je vous trouve d'une loyauté
sans faille mais quand même un peu
embarrassé sur le fond si je peux me
permettre si vous me
permettezie c'est bien que vous me
trouviez loyal parce que c'est
CEIS non c'est pas ce que je dis je dis
que la situation dans laquelle on s'est
mise est une situation qui a créé des
désordres très importantes dans les
esprits il y a des gens j'en connais
beaucoup que
cette séquence à profond attristé est-ce
que ça abîé la majorité est-ce que ça
abîé la majorité est-ce que le modem
fait toujours partie de la majorité ce
matin oui le modem fait partie de la
Major estce que les ministres du MoDem
vont rester au gouvernement le modem
fait partie de la majorité et le l'idée
que on se livrerait à des pousces au
CRIM n'est pas du tout la mienne mais je
suis très insatisfait de la manière dont
les choses ont été
conduites gouvernement majorité
opposition qui sont les on va prendre
les responsables gouvernement c'est
Elisabeth borne c'est Géral c'est c'est
quoi le problème ne me mettez pas dans
le rôle de procureur je c'est pas du
tout le mien et je sais que ces femmes
et ces hommes ont déployé beaucoup
beaucoup d'efforts pour trouver un texte
qui soit équilibré ellisabeth borne
s'est battu pied à pied pour que ce
texte existe et ne soit pas déséquilibré
et le ministre de l'Intérieur aussi je
suis pas là pour dire c'est la faute des
d'un d'un point de vue politique pardon
mais pour redonner du souffle à la
majorit est-ce qu'il faut par exemple un
changement est-ce qu'il faut un
remanimement est-ce qu'il faut un
gouvernement qui assume plus clairement
son ancrage à droite je
peux je ne crois pas du tout que ce soit
d'un côté ou de l'autre que se trouve la
solution du pays la solution du pays
elle est dans l'équilibre du bloc
central et je disais que donc il y a pas
besoin de remanimement pardon c'est pour
essayer de comprendre ça je je ne suis
pas président de la République non mais
vous lui parlez vous le conseillez et il
fait partie des rares personnes vous
faites partie des rares personnes qui
l'écoute pour l'instant euh le cette
décision elle est entre les mains du
Président de la
République de la première minist
qu'est-ce que vous lui conseillez est-ce
qu'il faut est-ce qu'il faut redonner du
souffle à cette majorité moi je
conseille de changer de méthode et de
pratique je pense que euh on ne peut pas
vivre les temps si difficiles qui sont
les nôtres en se livrant à des
surenchères d'un côté ou de l'autre il
faut euh affirmer réaffirmer s'il le
faut en tout cas qu'à défendre pied à
pied une vision qui soit une vision
équilibrée de l'avenir on vient de le
voir sur ce texte là vous croyez que on
on on peut avancer dans le pays en
désignant comme adversaire ou comme
ennemi une partie de la population qui
est sur notre sol h je ne le ferai
jamais je sais que la loi la plus
importante c'est celle que j'énonce on
va devoir vivre ensemble h alors ça
c'est le constat mais moi pardon je
voudrais que vous nous apportiez des des
propositions des solutions orénen
Rousseau le ministre de la Santé qui
présente sa démission à à Isabel est-ce
que vous le comprenez est-ce que la
premierre ministre doit accepter cette
démission ce matin je comprends très
bien les émotions qui se sont exprimées
hier je les comprends et je les partage
et je les ai partagé euh le la manœuvre
habile du rassemblement national a
troubler beaucoup d'esprit vous êtes
tombé les deux pieds dedans quand même
hein visiblement dans la manœuvre du
rassemblement national ben oui tout le
monde est tombé par parce que vous
comprenez vous l'avez
rappelé toute la vie politique toute ma
vie politique toute la vie politique de
la famille que je représente du courant
que je représente toute sa vie politique
elle a eu un marqueur c'est ne pas se
compromettre ou ne pas compromettre avec
l'extrémisme et notamment avec l'extrême
droite toute ma vie politique et toute
la leure et donc hier quand ils ont
découvert que le rassemblement national
plantait un drapeau sur un texte auquel
il s'était opposé
jusque-l très grand trouble dans les
esprits et je les comprends très grande
tristesse pour a le trouble d'un côté il
y a le besoin de clarté de l'autre
est-ce que Emmanuel Macron doit remanier
son équipe gouvernementale ben il me
semble que les décisions qui sont à
prendre aujourd'hui par le Président de
la République à propos du gouvernement
sont en effet une relance
nécessaire je pense je je pense que
forcément il va se poser la question du
Gouvernement et la majorité doit se
poser la question si vous proposez
d'aller à matinon demain ou dans
quelques mois est-ce que vous est-ce que
vous écouteriez la question vous savez
bien que je suis pour l'instant en
dehors complètement de ce type de
responsabilité parce
que il faut que s'achève la période
judiciaire qui s'était ouverte
mais
vous comprenez Si l'on ne rappelle pas
nos principes et je je pense le
président de la République va s'exprimer
ce soir sur sur votre chaîne sur sur
France 5 je pense qu'il est absolument
nécessaire de remettre
d'apelom la majorité ses idées et le
gouvernement et rendre la parole aux
Français la dissolution appeler les
Français aux urnes si vous voulez
ajouter du désordre au désordre allez
dans ce senslà c'est pas ça qu'il faut
faire que le le pire des risques dans
une démocratie ou un des pires risques
le virus le plus dangereux c'est le
désordre quand les gens ont l'impression
que c'est le bazar ils emploient même
des mots parfois un peu plus vifs que ça
que c'est le bazar qu'on ne s'y
reconnaît pas mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe comment comment on fait alors il
faut remettre de l'ordre remettrep
d'elom et je pense que c'est une
responsabilité que le Président de la
République doit maintenant assumer merci
beaucoup François Baou d'être venu dans
dans les 4V bonne journée merci